The newest trailer for Avengers: Endgame hit
in the early minutes of Super Bowl LIII.
And for most fans watching what turned out
to be one of the more mediocre Big Games in
recent memory, it was probably one of the
few actual highlights of the night.
The only real complaint we have about the
30 second spot?
It just wasn't long enough.
Still, with such a short running time, the
trailer was packed with details and moments
that seemed to hide plenty of significance.
While we can't know for sure what any of these
scenes might truly mean until the movie comes
out in late-April, we can definitely make
some educated — or not-so-educated — guesses.
Here are some of the small details in the
Big Game's Avengers: Endgame trailer that
you might've missed.
Potential spoilers ahead.
First, the trailer runs through ten shots
of MCU characters.
Who's in this blink-and-you'll-miss-it lineup?
Starting at the top, we see the Wasp; Nick
Fury; Spider-Man; Doctor Strange; Falcon;
Scarlet Witch; Star-Lord, Groot, Drax, Gamora,
and Rocket; Black Panther and a couple members
of the Dora Milaje; the Winter Soldier; and
the Vision.
With the exception of Rocket, and maybe those
two guards sharing the scene with T'Challa,
all of these characters were killed in Infinity
War, either after the Decimation, or directly
at Thanos's hands.
At first, it seems that these images simply
pay tribute to the characters who died in
the previous movie.
But there might be more going on here.
All the scenes are rendered in black-and-white...and
red.
Symbolically, red can represent life and death,
being easily associated with blood — you
know, the stuff you need to keep inside your
body to not die.
But this is a trailer for a movie involving
Infinity Stones — and the red one's the
Reality Stone.
There's been tons of speculation that time
travel will factor into the plot of Avengers:
Endgame.
But could these red-hued shots actually signify
that the Reality Stone will be the key to
their resurrection?
Who needs time travel if you can just ask
the Reality Stone to make some dead people
alive again?
We also see Clint Barton bathed in red light
in the trailer.
And we saw the dead Gamora in an orange light
— which many fans speculate to be her living
inside the Soul Stone — in Infinity War.
Let's put this theory in the "maybe" category.
The trailer officially kicks off with a shot
of the Statue of Liberty.
While that's usually a powerful symbol in
film, standing for freedom or America in general,
the details surrounding the statue are what
seem to be most significant.
It doesn't take long to realize that something
looks off about the area surrounding Liberty
Island — it's practically choked with boats
and ships.
For those of you who don't stare lovingly
at photos of Liberty Island every day, you
may not realize that this isn't something
that happens often...or really ever.
Compare the shot in the trailer to this photo
of Liberty Island on a typical day.
As you can see the amount of boats docked
there goes from "a whole lot" to "exactly
zero." (that’s a ferry not a boat)
The implication
here seems to be the utter desolation Thanos's
snap from the end of Avengers: Infinity War
has caused on the rest of the world.
People are fleeing their home cities — now
probably rendered completely broken due to
half the population blinking out of existence
— and are heading towards New York for refuge.
The image we get in the trailer makes sense,
too, since the decimation probably destroyed
air travel throughout the world.
Half the world's pilots and air traffic controllers
are all gone, right?
So instead, people are getting on boats and
sailing toward the most easily identifiable
port of entry they can find: the giant green
lady holding a torch right outside of Manhattan.
In a brief but significant moment from the
trailer, we got to see Tony Stark and Nebula
working together on...something.
The last time we saw those two, it seemed
like they were stranded in space together
on a spaceship.
Stark was recording a sad message for his
lady love, Pepper Potts, while Nebula was
just creeping through the ship.
Now we get a clear glimpse of the two of them
side-by-side, working on...well, again, we
still don't know what it is, since it's out
of frame.
But we can hazard a few guesses.
It could be repairs to the ship, which would
enable it to get wherever they're going more
quickly.
Maybe they're working on fixing up a suit
of Iron Man armor, which got busted in the
fight against Thanos.
Or maybe it's some other thing we don't know
about!
Either way, the most important revelation
here is that we know for sure that Stark and
Nebula are putting their skills together to
figure out how not to die in the cold, cold
vacuum of space.
There are a couple scenes in the trailer that
are conspicuous by what we don't see.
As we know by now, movie trailers may show
us previews of what we'll see when the movie
arrives.
But they'll just as often fudge the scenes
they depict in order to keep surprises at
a maximum.
The trailer for Infinity War showed Hulk running
behind the rest of the Avengers in Wakanda...and
we all know now that Hulk never showed up
during that fight scene in the finished film.
The new trailer for Endgame could be pulling
the same switcheroo.
Early in the trailer, we see a shot of Black
Widow, Captain America, Bruce Banner, and
War Machine walking outside of Avengers headquarters
— with a big old blank space where a fifth
character would seem to fit easily.
Another shot later shows the Avengers in profile,
lined up — with yet another space for an
apparently missing character.
If we assume that this is an example of Marvel
Studios misdirecting our attention to keep
certain spoilers off-screen, who could these
missing characters be?
If we believe these open spaces point to some
hidden characters, there are a few distinct
possibilities for who Marvel might be keeping
under wraps.
We know that Hawkeye is back in action in
Endgame, as he shows up at another point in
the trailer, so it seems unlikely that he'd
have been erased from these scenes.
But we still haven't caught sight of the Incredible
Hulk — even though we have seen Banner.
Could the Hulk have been separated from Banner
in this movie, which has happened before in
the comics?
We also know that Gwyneth Paltrow will be
in Avengers Endgame to reprise her role as
Pepper Potts.
It's not crazy to believe that Potts will
take on the role of Rescue, an identity she's
taken on in the comics while wearing one of
Stark's suits of Iron Man armor.
Seeing Potts in an Avengers group shot would
be a huge spoiler, so it makes sense that
Marvel might want to keep that particular
plot beat under its hat.
However, there's an even likelier person to
have been erased from the trailer...
It's very, very likely that the missing hero
is Captain Marvel, whose debut movie is set
to hit theaters about a month before Avengers:
Endgame drops.
We know from the end of Infinity War that
Captain Marvel will be important in this new
film, since her logo appears on Nick Fury's
pager just after he gets dusted.
But what other presence does Captain Marvel
have in this new trailer?
Surprisingly, the answer is lobsters.
Yes, that's right: lobsters.
In one of the few shots featuring Rocket,
the only surviving member of the Guardians
of the Galaxy, seems to reveal a couple of
interesting details about his possible location.
He opens up an old wooden door, with a shot
of a rocky shore behind him, along with a
couple of lobster traps.
So what, right?
Well, most of the country's lobsters come
from Maine...and according to The Life of
Captain Marvel comic book miniseries from
2018, Carol Danvers considers Harpswell, Maine,
her home away from home.
Meanwhile, the character's fictional biography
has her born in Boston, a New England location
that could certainly have a few lobster traps
lying around as well.
In either case, when you add in the fact that
Captain Marvel is a spacefaring hero, and
Rocket the alien raccoon seems to be the character
hanging out on the beach, it seems clear that
Marvel's hinting at Captain Marvel's impending
arrival to save the day.
Thor's whereabouts leave us with a lot more
guesswork than Rocket's.
We only get a couple of solo shots of the
Thunderer in the trailer: one's a close-up
of his face, while the next shot shows him
in silhouette at the mouth of some sort of
cave or structure.
In the distance we see the green of trees,
and what looks like a hill or a mountain.
The cave mouth itself seems unnatural, and
potentially man-made.
So...where is he?
There are a number of possibilities.
But like guessing what Stark and Nebula are
up to, all we can do is speculate wildly.
The colors of the landscape seem to look a
bit like Wakanda.
The cave, likewise, could be some kind of
base of operations for the Dora Milaje — we
know Okoye was left alive at the end of Infinity
War, even if the continued existence of T'Challa's
sister, Shuri, is in doubt.
Perhaps, however, this shot comes from wherever
Thanos ended up on at the end of Infinity
War.
The cave mouth — or maybe spaceship — doesn't
seem familiar at first glance, and we don't
yet know enough about where Thanos retired.
But plot-wise, it makes a lot of sense for
Thor to visit his former foe, so he could
retrieve the Infinity Gauntlet and undo Thanos's
damage.
Of course, we know that it got fried right
after the snap in the last movie, so the sad
look on his face could indicate a dead end.
When James "War Machine" Rhodes and Scott
"Ant-Man" Lang last met, it was as enemies
in Captain America: Civil War.
The two characters took up opposite sides
of the superheroic conflict, and we've never
seen them interact as anything other than
enemies.
In fact, Ant-Man and Captain America basically
threw a truck filled with gasoline at the
guy.
"Throw it at this.
Now!"
"Oh come on!"
Needless to say, the two of them didn't have
the kind of introduction that makes for friendship.
However, we know for sure that both characters
will have important parts to play in Endgame
— especially when Ant-Man drives up in his
Ant-Van at the end of the first trailer Marvel
Studios released for the film.
The new trailer doesn't give us much, but
we do see the pair standing side-by-side,
getting suited up and ready for action.
It stands to reason that whatever beef these
two had with each other has been sufficiently
squashed — at least until reality and/or
the timeline gets reset by the end of the
movie.
Captain America is pretty inextricably linked
to his famous shield.
But believe it or not, he hasn't held the
thing up since the end of Captain America:
Civil War.
He was rocking a different shield entirely
in Infinity War — sort of a triangular,
black buckler that was provided by T'Challa
in Wakanda.
But in this new trailer for Endgame, we get
a shot of what seems to be the inside of Captain
America's classic shield.
The circumstances of him reclaiming this weapon
are a big question mark.
Last time we saw it was when he threw it at
Tony Stark's feet after the two of them finished
fighting in Civil War.
"My father made that shield."
Maybe Cap swung by Tony's empty penthouse
to pick it up?
Or maybe this is yet more grist for the mill
when it comes to the constant time travel
theories that continue to follow this movie.
Regardless of how he gets his hands on it,
everyone knows just one thing:
When Captain America throws his mighty shield,
all those who chose to oppose his shield must
yield!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.